that was the scene in an Egyptian
courtroom on Monday as three al Jazeera
journalists were sentenced to jail for
seven to ten years the Instagram video
is just one of thousands of reactions to
the verdict online I'm Dina and this is
hashtag where we're following the story
as it unfolds on social media the
hashtags free aj staff and aj trial
trended globally as an Egyptian judge
convicted journalist from Hamlet fat me
Peter greste and Mohammed of aiding the
Muslim Brotherhood and falsely reporting
the news accusations al-jazeera denies
more than forty one thousand tweets
included the hashtag AJ trial when the
verdict came down on Monday and more
than 67,000 featured the hashtag free AJ
staff which has actually been trending
since februari journalists worldwide
were among the most vocal online when
the news broke Sky News is Sherine
Tadros a former al-jazeera correspondent
herself tweeted as a friend I feel
incredibly sad as a journalist I'm
scared as an Egyptian I'm ashamed
hashtag AJ trial and Larry King posted
journalism is not a crime hashtag free
aging staff Lena atala who writes for
the independent Egyptian news site meta
must've added ten and seven years it
could have been us in a phone
conversation with AJ plus I holla summed
up the mood in Egypt the mainstream
media Egypt office area but there's
anything wrong with deferred in fact
some Egyptians have used the same
hashtag AJ trial to voice their support
for the sentencing Egyptian Eagle
tweeted thousands of Egyptians were and
still are killed by Al Jazeera lies and
support to terrorism we can't forgive
them but much of the outrage on social
has centered around the trials lack of
evidence guilty verdicts in the AJ trial
despite evidence that included pictures
of horses from another network and
vacation shops for the journalists
family members like Peters brother
Andrew cresta the verdict was much more
personal he tweeted gutted devastated
dumbfounded shattered can't describe the
emotions of today's out
there are at least 11 other journalists
being held in Egyptian prisons according
to the Committee to Protect Journalists
Sharif Jabba summed up the reality in
Egypt like this
for more on this story and other
hashtags subscribe to our YouTube
channel and thanks for watching